I could give an intro to Tolkien and his influence
on the fantasy genre - but instead, I’ll
quote beloved humorist and author, Terry Pratchett.
Said Pratchett in 2010: “[Tolkien] has become
a sort of mountain, appearing in all subsequent
fantasy in the way that Mt. Fuji appears so
often in Japanese prints. Sometimes it’s
big and up close. Sometimes it’s a shape
on the horizon. Sometimes it’s not there
at all, which means that the artist either
has made a deliberate decision against the
mountain, [...] or is in fact standing on
Mt. Fuji.” - Terry Pratchett
So Tolkien is widely regarded as the most
influential author on the fantasy genre…
period. But one of the less-discussed aspects
of his work is the way Tolkien used constructed
language in his writing.
Nowadays authors are constantly making up
words and languages for the worlds they build,
but Tolkien was unique in that he constructed
languages first, and then created worlds so
his fictional languages would have somewhere
to live.
In 1958, he wrote in a letter to his son Christopher:
“[The Lord of the Rings] was an attempt
to create a world in which a form of language
agreeable to my personal aesthetic might seem
real”
And In a lecture he gave to some fellow philologists
In 1931, Tolkien described his fondness for
constructing fictional languages as a “secret
vice” - almost like a shameful hobby. But
Tolkien’s “secret vice” wasn’t just
a strange quirk, it ended up as one of the
most influential aspects of everything he
wrote.
Let’s talk a little bit about constructed
languages, or as they’re called in the Community,
a thing that exists, “ConLangs”
According to linguist Arika Okrent: “There
are trends, or eras, in language invention
that reflect the preoccupations of the surrounding
culture, and so, in a way, the history of
invented languages is a story about the way
we think about language”
According to Okrent, the history of constructed
languages is, for most of its history, extremely
utilitarian. Between the 17th-18th centuries,
the idea of a constructed Universal language
was thought of as a way of cataloging and
understanding the world, and is linked with
the development of science and mathematical
notation, as opposed to natural language which
was seen as flawed where it was not logical.
But by the 19th Century, attention shifted
to the social use of language; in 1887, polish
linguist L. L. Zamenhof invented Esperanto,
to this day the most widely spoken constructed
language in the world. It was described as
an “easy and flexible language that would
serve as a universal second language to foster
peace and international understanding”
But Tolkien was not the first to invent language
in fiction – Sir Thomas More’s 1516 book
Utopia, Francis Godwin’s 1638 book Man in
the Moone, and Jonathan Swift’s Gulliver's
Travels, became important landmarks in the
early use of language invention. Swift created
names, place names and phrases in several
languages spoken of places like Lilliput and
brobdingnag
But none of these examples reach the level
of complexity of Tolkien’s languages. According
to Okrent: “...these creations usually aren’t
languages so much as they are ideas, a bit
of vocabulary, a few phrases. … They serve
the story, never the other way around… For
Tolkien, language creation was an art all
its own.”
Tolkien intertwined myth and language to create,
in his words, an “illusion of historicity.”
From his earliest language writing in 1907
all the way to his death in the 1970’s,
Tolkien never stopped developing what he called
his ‘nexus of languages’”
Tolkien didn’t just see language creation
as a hobby, but an art, akin to writing fiction,
and saw the two is as intertwined.In his own
words: “For perfect construction of an art-language
it is found necessary to construct at least
in outline a mythology concomitant […] the
converse indeed is true -- your language construction
will breed a mythology.”
He notes that in contrast to more utilitarian
constructed languages like Esperanto, his
interest was in associating language invention
with pleasure.
But Tolkien tended to downplay his languages
to friends and family, calling it his “secret
vice” and using such dismissive and self-deprecating
ways to describe them as “my nonsense fairy
language,” “unpublished inventions known
only to my family,” and “the shame-faced
revelation of specimens of my own more considered
effort.”
By the time Tolkien started working on The
Hobbit in The Early 1930s he had already invented
the “Nexus of languages” which gave his
nomenclature, again in his words, a “coherence
and consistency” that he found lacking in
“other name inventors.”
The first instance we see of this nexus is
simply the mention of “Moria” -- Moria
is a Noldorin, later Sindarin or your basic
Elvish name meaning “Black Chasm”
We’d later also know it by its Dwarvish
name, Khazad-dûm
But while there is evidence of Tolkien's language
invention serving his nomenclature in The
Hobbit, it was not until the publication of
the first entry in the Lord of the Rings trilogy,
The Fellowship of the Ring in 1954, that readers
were given the first longer samples of his
Elvish languages.
On page 80 of Fellowship, Frodo flexes his
language skills by speaking Elen síla lúmenn’
omentielvo, “A star Shines on the hour of
our meeting”, you go, Frodo, work those
college language credits.
This is the first example of an Elvish language,
in this case the high Elven language of quenya,
appearing as dialog in the text.
Later in the same volume, some elves speak
it and we also get some poems - Galadriel’s
lament aka “Namárië” which means “farewell”
Language is a recurring theme throughout the
books -- even the tree-like ents not only
get a few “inaccurate” (Treebeard’s
words, not mine) sampling of their own extremely
slow and thoughtful language, but also discuss
the way it differs from the languages of elves,
dwarves and men. It’s not only extremely
slow, it’s also highly detailed.
Even the Elves, master linguists, could not
learn Old Entish.
And in Return of the King we get appendices
that talk a LOT about the languages and the
“translation” (Tolkien acting as a historian,
not a fiction writer, tee hee)
Here he equivocates “Westron” - the common
language of men, with Modern English, and
Rohirric, the language of Rohan, with Old
English, and so on..
But Tolkien’s mythology is most meticulously
developed in The Silmarillion , which is Tolkien
in full self-indulgence mode. It was published
posthumously, so we don’t know what he would
have wanted the reader in on exactly, but
it’s the most detailed outlining of his
mythology that’s been published.
So let’s talk specifics about this nexus
of languages.
Sindarin - Spoken by the Grey Elves - basically
the “common tongue” of elves in middle
earth in the third age, when LotR takes place,
so Legolas, Elrond and Arwen - they speak
Sindarin. It has characteristics similar to
Welsh and other Celtic languages (such as
Irish, Manx, Scottish, and Cornish)
Quenya is the language of the Eldar after they return
to Middle Earth - so it’s the primary language
of high elves like Galadriel and Celeborn,
but the elves of Lothlórien still speak Sindarin
on the day to day. So it’s considered a
high, formal language - Aragorn speaks it
sometimes .
Quenya’s biggest real-world language influence
was Finnish, which was JRR’s fave, and its
use in Finnish epics like “The Kalevala”
Quenya focused on the use of open, long vowels,
and his sound combination rules emphasized
a softening of consonant stops; all elements
of Finnish phonetics
That said, many of the words in Quenya tend
to end in open vowels (e.g.. Norolinde, pirukendea,
nieninqea), whereas in Sindarin words tend
to end in consonants (hindar, Nebrachar, magradhaid)
giving Sindarin a different sound aesthetic
than Quenya. Quenya and Sindarin both descend
from a common ancestor, Quendian, because
Tolkien wanted his elvish languages to feel
lived in, and to evolve like real languages
do.
So where English, German, Spanish, Irish,
Persian and Hindi all descend from the same
proto-langauge and are in the same language
family, so it goes with Elvish languages.
This is in contrast to--
Black speech is almost kind of a parody of
international auxiliary languages like Esperanto.
Sauron “created” it to be its own evil
language inaccessible to outsiders - not an
organic language within a language family
that evolved over time.
The most famous use of this, of course, the
inscription on the One Ring, even though it’s
written in an Elvish script (we’ll get to
that).
Weirdly, in-universe it’s mostly restricted
to Sauron’s evil higher-ups like the Nazgul
that speak it - most orcs just speak like
a cockney variant on Westron (English)
And then there’s the Dwarves and their Dwarvish
language, Khuzdul. Based partially on Semitic
languages like Arabic and Hebrew, --
Yeah, about that...
Tolkien noted some similarities between Dwarves
and Jewish people: both were, in his words:
"at once natives and aliens in their habitations,
speaking the languages of the country, but
with an accent due to their own private tongue…".
Tolkien stated that "[Dwarves’] words
are Semitic obviously, constructed to be Semitic."
So, yeah, maybe a little tone deaf.
Khuzdul has its own script that is based on
nordic runes, and is derived from Cirth,
another invention of Tolkien. But in universe
not much is known about it, because the Dwarves
keep it ~secret~, so it has very little vocabulary
compared to Elvish languages
Tengwar, the writing system used to write
Elvish and black speech, is utilized much
more in terms of script. Most famous use - One
ring to rule them all/Ash nazg durbatulûk,
ash nazg gimbatul
It has been described as a script that looks
like a "mixture of Hebrew, Greek, and Pitman's
shorthand,” but we can only speculate on
what writing systems influenced Tengwar. The
way it incorporates vowels reminds me of abugida
scripts like Devanagari, which is used for
north indian languages like Hindi.
So given all we know about these languages,
is it possible to speak Quenya and Sindarin?
No.
The vocabulary, grammar, and syntax of Tolkien's
invented languages, even of Quenya and Sindarin,
are far too incomplete to allow its casual,
conversational, or quotidian use.
So a lot of what you see in the movies is
guesswork, much of which was constructed by
linguist David Salo, who kinda filled in the
plugs in the DNA sequence gaps with frog DNA.
Even before the publication of the final volume
of The Lord of the Rings, fans begin to write
to Tolkien to ask for more information about
his invented languages. And he actually indulged
them… for a little while
Un...til they started calling his house in
the middle of the night and he had to move
and remove his listing from the phone book
Starting in the 1960’s, Linguists and scholars
began to create societies dedicated to the
study of his languages, like the Elvish Linguistic
Fellowship, which collabed w/ JRR’s son
Christopher in the 90’s to edit and publish
his father's numerous manuscripts of detailed
linguistic material.
Ever since, there have been Tolkien language
bulletins, magazines, and societies popping
up dedicated to studying his languages.
And they exploded in popularity with the release
of the lord of the rings films, starting in
2001.
And Tolkien’s influence lives on
Richard Adams’s Watership Down has the rabbit
language “Lapine” which is integrated
throughout the text so that the reader absorbs
it through context clues, So when towards
the end of the book good rabbit tells bad
rabbit “Silflay hraka u enmeer rah”
- effectively, $$%$##&*(&&^%
- the reader understands it without needing
it translated
Nowadays, conlangs are in the popular mainstream.
As Star Trek was becoming A Thing just as
LotR was exploding in popularity in the US,
Klingon - the most immediate (and obvious)
descendant, is now the most highly developed
conglang there is … that we know of...
And also has the highest number of speakers
for any fictional conlang (besides Esperanto, which
is still …. trying.)
Now producers of movies and tv shows actually
hire professional linguists and members of
conlang societies to build languages for dialogue.
The Dothraki language in George RR Martin’s
ASOIAF which Martin had only briefly outlined
in the novels was developed into a full functioning
language in Game of Thrones.
And for Avatar, James Cameron hired linguist
Paul Frommer to create the Na’vi language
(largely based on Polynesian languages and
things that sound “tribal yet futuristic”
like the Papyrus font)
Even video games like Skyrim and Dragon Age
have their own language systems. In Skyrim
learning to use the dragon language is a crucial
part of the gameplay.
Tolkien’s work played a crucial role in
elevating language invention to a key part
of inventing imaginary worlds and elements
of invented language are now part and parcel
of science fiction + fantasy.
David Peterson, who fleshed out George R.
R. Martin’s Dothraki and High Valyrian languages
from a few words to fully fleshed out conlangs,
claims that prior to 1991, people looked down
on conlangers…
But, post 2015, he says the conlang community
has really taken off… “There are conlangers
active on Tumblr, Twitter, and Facebook who
have no connection to any of the original
communities--and they’re drawing inspiration
from languages that didn’t exist even five
years ago.” (15-17)
So it's kind of funny that Tolkien was so
shy about the fact that he had a hobby of
inventing languages, since it ended up being
incredibly influential on not just fantasy
fiction but fiction in general.
So don’t be ashamed of your “secret vice”
- post that cringe - you might accidentally
invent a genre.